All right, everybody. So here is example number two. So over here, you can see we have this low
we had a market structure shift here and
Consecutive bearish candles or down close candles is your autoblock if I mark the autoblock
Like that
You can clearly see that price ripped through the autoblock taking out the autoblock liquidity and afterwards
We had a reclaim and then a retest. I'm looking at an S100 and you can see that price just went up like that
so
You can clearly see that we took out sell side here, right and they made it look look so obvious
You the sell side was taken we had a market structure shift
so a lot of us into traders would try to go along either off this fair value gap or
This entire autoblock what happens price takes out the slow
and
You might be asking me that
What about other trading strategies?
Now we are doing this without bias, okay?
So this is a no delia boss strategy. That is when we're gonna use this method and
It's not gonna happen all the time
most of the time or
Some sometimes it's gonna react off this very well gap and go up. It's not gonna be a case where it happens every time
but
If you see a pattern like this where you have a sweep, right?
Let's say your initial entry was here and you lost rate
But you can do is look for this pattern where price reclaims itself
Like that closes above it. So this is very important closes above it and you have like a
Target level this could be a take profit one. This could be your take profit to
Let's move on to another example